the game
oh I thought it was coming if I pop wait there it is moe moe
boo moe wee boo
moee I missed you It's Minto That's me Hot dog Minto Misto
Yeah We're gonna beat Misto today We're gonna do it We're
gonna Oh wait I think I'm okay Um Last time I had like a
walkthrough pulled up But I didn't touch it at all So Um I
think I think maybe With you guys Helping me out We'll be
okay maybe I forgot to pull it up this time because I didn't
use it.
I didn't even think about it.
Good luck on beating Myst today.
Thank you!
The backseaters will guide us.
Yes.
Too smart.
And also, I have my resources, aka you.
I, um, okay.
I played Myst a couple days ago.
Two days ago.
And...
I said then, I can't keep playing Myst because I have a
meeting.
And you know what?
That meeting got moved to today.
So I have to beat it.
I have to beat it before my meeting in three hours.
I think we could do it.
Yeah, it was like, seems doable.
Yeah, you think so.
I think we can do it.
I think we could do it.
I don't want to rush or anything, but...
the turn tables.
It was funny because I was like ready for the meeting.
I was like, okay, let's go.
And then Phoebe was like, um, actually my family wanted to
eat dinner today.
They changed the date for me.
And we were like, oh, we can't.
She was like, I'll join like, I'll go in another room and
join via mobile.
And we were like, we can't have you miss your dinner with
your family.
So, um,
So, let's load back in, baby.
I went to Phoebe's stream after yours and was like, um...
Ah, yeah.
It's okay, though.
Alrighty, okay, okey-dokey.
Let's get my bearings.
Oh, I have to pull up my notes that I took.
Let's see.
I wrote some notes before.
Like, the sunken ship.
The spaceship we did.
That was the 59 volts.
The gear we have not done.
The metal gear.
Hello, meantime.
Viewers like you.
My advice for the day.
Check the expiration date on your milk before you bring it
to work.
Mario almost got me too.
No way!
Yeah, the big clank.
The big clank.
Let's go take a look at it real quick.
How do...
Is there anything even to do here?
Like, there's nothing for me to click, is there?
I'm clicking everywhere?
What was the hint you got from the tower?
Um, it was 2.40, 2.2.
Like, 2.40 time.
2.1 for the gear.
town at least.
I don't understand at all.
Does it ever do anything?
No.
No of any clocks.
We're there.
the dentist.
Oh, I hope it's scary.
I didn't turn on the line.
But they didn't give me a date.
So I think we're a...
Okay.
Door closing.
IMP3.
Um, we did here.
Hold on.
There's also something about the sunken ship I wrote.
Let's see, what did I write?
October 11th, 1984, 10.04 a.m.
And then January 17th, 1207, 554, 5.46 a.m.
November 23rd, 9,791, 657 p.m.
Something about the sunken ship.
Wait, the clock!
But I can't do anything with this guy.
Wait, 240?
Two?
I wonder if it's like two, like, spin two, spin two, spin
two.
one or something and then he tries I wonder but this is
definitely not too full wait does it spin the time oh it
does oh my gosh wait 240 35 40 I can't see it is Is that it
right there?
It's nonsensical!
Wait.
Five.
Please!
Six.
Seven, eight, nine.
Ten, eleven, twelve.
One, two.
you guys I might be a genius what's in here and then it's
two to one oh no what is the hell what is this one two one I
wonder if there's a two two
Oh gosh.
2, 2, 3.
Oh, it's so close!
This is so close.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Oh.
Hello?
Uh-oh.
Did I mess it up?
Thank you.
Reset!
oh
oh just kidding i'm an idiot i was like two two one because
i was looking at the one here okay hold on we could figure
this out wait wait wait oh well
we could figure this out maybe probably
oh i'm Did it just reset?
Set the numbers even?
Let me see.
Oh, it does.
I'm stupid.
Guys, why does this feel like?
It feels like when I'm doing those, what's the words?
Like the puzzle, the slide puzzles.
It feels like one of those.
Hi, Minto.
Hello.
Mm-hmm.
Feels very...
Okay.
Does it go...
Hold on.
I'm going to see...
Okay.
I see.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so close.
if only I'm here again
I wish it let me go more than I wish it let me mess up as
much as I wanted to you know without this thing going all
the way down I wish I didn't have to reset the game is
clearly like it's a skill issue if you can't get it within
this number of within this number of tries it's a skill
issue Try holding the lever.
Thanks for coming to Asakioru on Saturday, I'm in town.
Oh, of course.
If I hold it...
It only does that metal!
Oh, my gosh.
That's why I was so mad.
See, yeah, I would have never...
I probably would have never done it, though.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Alright.
Ta-da!
Today's my birthday!
I was wondering if you could wish me a happy birthday.
Thanks for the stream.
Fain Rear!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I believe in you, that believes in you.
I'm believing, we're believing.
What did it do?
Wait, mysterious music happened and then...
Wait, this opened.
Wait, does that reset it?
Like, does this close?
Oh, I messed up.
Okay, I have to do it over again.
I didn't think that would do that.
My bad.
Okay, wait.
Do you think then the gear over here is now open?
But also, we must see if the...
Okay, the really loud...
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
I turn it down?
If this now...
Oh, okay.
The tower does not need the rotation.
probably because it's this it's connected to that gear so i
think we're okay all right let's go inside the gear the
clank mgs fox now gives xp for custom matches no way we need
to do it like a member stream or something oh it's open whoa
what is this oh it's a book let's go we're going to the
metal Whoa!
Whoa!
Is this a roller coaster?
All the gears are making me think of Star Skates.
We're here.
What is here anyway?
Water.
Well, expensive water.
What's this do?
Hmm, okay.
Imagine I like just, I was like, la la la la la.
And I got it?
That'd be crazy.
What's this?
This looks like it'll open up.
Wow.
Oh.
Metal Gear Jojinchi, let's go!
The snake?
Oh my god.
It's really Metal Gear.
Ow!
Thank you.
Wait.
Just in the CEO...
Um...
Wait, what?
Thank you so much for the 50 gift!
What?
What is your history?
What is it?
What's this?
Oh...
Whoa, I'm clicking on literally everything.
Okay.
Let's continue.
Oh, what's here?
Oh,
okay.
Okay, so I can only...
I can't let go.
I don't think so.
Okay.
It's red now.
What does that mean?
Oh, this is red now, okay?
Does it change anything in here?
Wait, what the heck is this?
I completely missed this!
Oh my god.
There's just...
Fortress Rotation Simulator Calibrating, okay?
There's just knobs and levers after knobs and levers.
Okay.
Am I turning it at all or...
Oh, here we go.
Bink!
Wait, is it the same as like north is this sound?
And then...
Oh, no, please.
Yeah, oh no.
I've heard these sounds before!
These sounds before...
I've played...
I've played these games before.
What is this, though?
I thought it would open when we turned red.
Oh.
Hello, madam.
We got a boat.
That looks like the one that's sunk in our...
In our spaceship!
Wait a second.
These are our goods.
They're little miniatures.
what the hell is going on in this sorry it was so bright oh
my gosh
and then there's the what are these I can't press them they
do nothing there's every oh
there's chest
a bird
There is nonsensical everything going on in here.
Okay, did I change anything when I rotated it?
Flashbang.
I literally got flashbang.
Huh.
That was a simulator.
Even the thing I did downstairs?
When I rotated it red?
Okay.
Alright, I don't think I can go...
Oh, I think I need to be able to turn this so we can go over
there.
Yeah, what I did was real, but it didn't turn anything.
There's so many things.
There's so many things to look at.
I'm going to try this again.
Yes!
Oh, what's this?
I can't grab the knife.
Okay.
Alright, let's...
Oh, no.
That's not where I wanted to go.
This way.
Let's try this room again.
If I...
If I close it, I didn't actually get to look at what the red
was.
So let's go inside.
Oh!
Oh, see!
I should have just done that.
Oh, my God.
I have a boon.
Cool.
Oh, what is that?
Oh.
So there's a timer?
Let's try...
Different.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
There!
That's only rotating the inner though.
We want the outer as well.
We have to find a way to rotate the outer.
Yeah, we only have the one lever.
I wonder if it's...
Oh, now I can't go in here.
Only when it's red can I use the elevator.
I don't even know where to start, you guys.
Let's go back to this bird.
And then this is the little clock.
Okay, and we might get flashbanged again, I'm so sorry.
Please glow, but don't do anything right now.
This I can't do anything with?
Okay.
If I click on the lady, nothing happens.
Each room has its own soundtrack.
It's very exciting.
I've
had a complete total loss.
No, I don't want to do this one again!
Fortress Rotation Simulator!
This was a simulation game this whole time, you guys.
Hey!
Get me out of here!
And then this is open, but I can't open it.
I could only look what's even the puzzle your guess is as
good as mine your guess is we have two rooms
we have
it's so nonsensical
hi I'm the new minfa and I met you during the asayadu collab
I'm so glad to be you to be my first ever meet in green i
can't wait to see you again in the future meet the brother
thank you oh my gosh thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you
i'll stop this but i don't think this is until
uh until over here
thank you so much uh
The puzzle is a puzzle in itself.
I know.
I think if anyone wants to give me a hint of where to start.
Of like something I should be looking at.
Vague, vague hint.
So I can try.
I'm like literally clicking everything.
But I'm noticing this one is green and this one is red.
I don't know if that has anything to do with it.
Is your brain currently debuffs because you're not wearing
the smarty glasses?
No!
The elevator, okay, the elevator.
I see you guys saying elevator.
No, thank you so much!
For them, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna test something real quick.
Does it turn red?
It's also like...
Okay, it only turns red here, okay.
Alright, ride the elevator, they say.
Can I go down?
Nope.
See what this is.
The mid-floor.
I can't turn around.
So let's go.
There is no window.
Am I crazy?
Oh!
What is this?
Those are the levers I need, no?
Oh, wait.
I think what we have to do...
Isn't this the timer?
Yeah.
Because it's up here.
If the lever goes down...
Or if the elevator goes down.
Oh!
Okay.
Um.
Oh.
My bad.
That's what happens.
happens.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
World's worst architect.
Right, for real.
I guess this arrow is supposed to indicate that you look up,
huh?
They're like, hey, idiot.
There's a... It's the yellow gamer paint of the 90s.
They're like, Look up!
Look up!
Alright, let's see if I...
Whoa.
Where are we?
Oh, oh shoot.
What sound was that?
We are wanting to look...
Um...
To the right.
East?
That was west sound.
Okay, we want to look east.
in his house.
Why is there no visual?
Who invented this?
Where's the sound?
Oh, bunk.
Oh, gosh.
I can't remember the sounds at all.
Even back in the 90s, they apparently understood gamer
habits quite well.
Bunk.
Bunk was south.
It's south.
Bunk.
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
Sproing?
I thought Sproing was south.
Maybe I just never went south.
Is this east then?
Sproing is east.
All right, let's see.
It's an awfully quiet rotator, huh?
Like, everything else is so loud.
we're rotating the giant machine.
There's nothing.
Ah!
We made it!
To the other side.
What is this?
What?
Okay, I'll take a picture.
Okay, well, no, I don't need a picture.
The last two are three peaks and half moon.
Actually, I will take a picture.
Good soundproofing.
Yeah.
like yeah not twin peaks three peaks I took a picture so
it's okay wait so is there an island on the other side I
actually there has to be because well
not half maybe there's one behind because I don't remember I
don't remember seeing anything and
then I guess we also have to rotate
for the...
the telescope.
Oh, wait.
Oh, just kidding.
Yeah, this is what we're supposed to do.
Okay, uh...
I'll try rotating it to the...
north.
Wait.
Yeah, north?
And seeing if there's anything that was behind the island,
you know?
Yep.
North!
Wait, that's north, right?
What the fuck?
All right.
Wait, that was south?
Oh, shh.
I see.
They sound so similar to me.
I mean, I guess I could have put in the two shapes that we
just got, but that's okay.
Okay.
Here.
No, I went too far, I think.
Sounds like a bomb is about to go off.
For real, though.
Alright.
Alright, let's see if there's anything here.
Excuse me, Miss.
I was right.
My intuition.
Yes, my intuition.
No!
Because I was like, I don't remember seeing anything over
here.
You can... Obviously, I saw this one, so I was like, maybe
it's behind us.
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait, I just noticed, like, the...
Alright, so then, let's go back.
Let's go back south.
We still need a blue page.
We'll find it somehow.
Intuition.
Why are you putting that in quotes, huh?
Do you doubt my genius?
Oh, wait.
Do you doubt my...
I mean, look how big my head is.
There's got to be something in this noggin.
There's got to be something.
It's not totally rattling...
What's the sound?
No.
That's West.
Yes.
At least three brain cells in here.
This was the reason of gamers going bald in the 90s.
Maybe.
Technically, your head is empty since you're a ghost.
What?
I have plenty of actoplasm.
What do
you mean it's empty?
Oops.
Oh, please turn around.
There we go.
All right.
Let's go put in our symbols.
Phone.
Thank goodness I don't have to write notes.
Down.
and then like some ziggy zaggies.
Ziggy zaggies.
And then I think I remember it was the three peaks.
And then half a moon.
There isn't a right half, right?
I'll double check.
No.
There's not.
Oh, I missed it again.
Oh.
8008.
Baby?
Wait.
Eh.
Wait, home already?
No, no, no.
We haven't gotten the page!
Wait, we didn't get the page yet.
We have to go back.
So you're doing your balloon stream.
We made a deal.
I try to meet girls, meet people.
If I'm still single by 30, you'd summon Lila.
to wish me happy birthday and our own nesan boys today turn
30 made new friends at con got roasted by rio juice for
liking anime that's a con at an anime otaku convention hope
you're having a good holiday season you too wait what thank
you so much for the akashub and all i have to summon lilac
Okay, oh, geez.
I don't remember making this promise, but probably that I
did.
Maybe.
Oh, wait.
What am I doing?
Here we go.
This one?
Yeah.
What is going on?
Hold on, one second.
My phone is bugging.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I don't even know how to do Onesan voice.
I will try.
Oh, Blyback doesn't even have Onesan voice.
Ghost of meat.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday!
Thank you again so much for the...
For the...
Akasupa, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Alrighty.
Let's figure out what's going on in here.
Okay, I think we need to...
Is it this one?
No, it's the other room.
I don't know if this has to do with
with the other island or not.
and then these telescope does not have to do any anything
with the pages okay thank you very much
i was wondering if it was gonna like that's why i was
wondering if it showed something with the island the thrones
hide a secret then i'm guessing this is the blue pages then
i'm assuming this This is the blue pages and then this is if
I want the red pages.
So let's uh, what the thrones?
What secrets do they hide?
Examine the thrones very carefully.
There's blood there.
I think I found it.
Um, whoops.
Hope you have a good time, Minto.
In fact, Marty O'Donnell worked on this and went to do the
music where Halo and Destiny are.
Wow, cool.
I found it!
What's this?
Oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, what was that?
Where is that?
Oh.
Very, very.
Wait, I want to find the other one, too, then.
That's so funny.
Is it like one of these?
No.
There's this, but...
How do I...
Hmm.
Such a nice obedience cage.
At least Eustace isn't messed up.
Wait, but then there's also this.
I can't tell what's like a red herring, if anything.
You know?
Does his throne have it in a different location?
I'm pointing and I'm clicking.
I'm playing the game.
Sure, we're still on Team Blue?
I might have like eaten my words as soon as...
Like, what the heck?
Mr. Man!
Oh, whoa, I didn't... Oh my god.
It's literally him!
Whoa!
I don't see it here, though.
Am I blind?
Wait.
Is she blind?
Yes.
Why?
This one is slightly better hidden.
Tapestry?
Oh my god.
that was like just a full-on like this is where it's at
thank you oh please let me go forward in the room aha oh my
god he just hid all his gold and riches in here and wines i
think if i didn't know any better this room belong to matara
khan okay
uh let me ask out of here.
Please.
Thank you.
We got our page.
I feel like we should go get the other pages real quick.
Are you guys ready for some quality?
144p television.
Here he comes.
I'm my friend.
I'll bring in the blue pages.
I see something.
Huh?
Convinced.
The Sirus is killed deeply.
Pray do not release him.
Sirus.
He will destroy me.
Just as he does.
The innocent bystander.
I've been wrongly tricked.
You don't poison me!
Not the filter.
The red filter.
I think you have a concern.
He's employed with lust for riches!
In the four remaining worlds.
Use and plot.
He was almost perfect!
Riches!
Although it was a father.
It took him into believing.
What kind of camera is he using?
Who was the murderer?
How did you murder father?
Bring me the remaining.
It's his leave.
He's using the pages.
iPhone 1.
This literal book camera.
Book camera.
From the last age of mischief.
I must be free.
Must be free.
Get up there here for eternity.
I must be free.
Free me.
This acting is like...
He's so like...
What
I'm gonna do is...
I'm gonna save this as like...
You guys... Okay, I know...
I think it was like what?
There was like...
Four different endings.
We always enjoy our quality with this guy.
Corona, welcome back.
Thank you.
Four endings.
I'm assuming one is if you do only the blue pages one is if
you do red only the red pages and one is if you do red and
blue pages maybe but i don't know what the last one would be
no pages
not necessarily i don't know i see one is if you get no
pages i see you're only locked into an ending at the very
end oh really wait so i could collect the red pages at this
very moment and it would be okay
uh where have we gone sorry where are we gone we've gotten
spaceship uh the red page let's go just let's just let's
just go wait
was the really awful one with the subway, right?
Locked in at the very, very end, so you don't need to worry.
Okay, I should...
All right, we'll get it over with...
Whoops, that's not what I meant to do.
We'll just get it over with...
I'm like, all right, let's, I think it was the one over
here, right?
Yes.
I remember.
My big brain.
Oh, oops.
Yes, we're zooming?
Come on, get on with it!
Alrighty.
Here we go.
Here we go!
The loading between screens used to be so long.
I mean, back then.
It is actually, I feel like playing the game, like, or
rather, this feels playable, you know, compared to...
to back then when everything was like crazy loading times
and everything like it's just it's just nice thank you all
right you remember we members yeah
that's east is that east no wait no that's west i'm so sorry
I lied.
I remembered at the very last second.
Weast.
Thank you, everybody.
It's like playing BA on PC.
Really?
I played it once and it crashed and I've never touched it
again.
Maybe I should give it another try.
Did you guys...
If you played Blue Archive, did you pull for...
Sayya and did you pull for Hasumi?
South.
Is that the next one?
South?
We'll hear it in two seconds.
One, two.
No, that's east.
I didn't get Sayya.
I got extremely lucky with my pulls.
I did the first free pull.
I did the first free pull And then I always, like, do one of
my own jemmies, and I did that, and that's when I got Seya.
And then they had the free Tenpole ticket that they give you
as well for the anniversary, and I used that, and I got
Hasumi.
Like, immediately!
It was crazy!
That's East also, right?
Oh, we talking Saint Seya?
No!
That's South!
who are you polling for the other 90 polls more seya
i was laying in bed and i was doing my polls and when when
seya came i literally jumped up i was like this is unheard
of if you don't know me with gotcha luck i don't have any so
this is like unprecedented it's like craziness i went feral
for you
east or no west sorry i did it again i did it i did I did it
again!
I did it again!
Oops, I...
Did it again...
No!
Your luck is changing mint, it can't always be bad.
I don't know, I'm a ghost, so it's just kind of like...
Part of the...
Part of the equation.
I just pulled Seya!
Let's go!
Next?
Oh shoot, I forgot that.
Oh my god, wait.
What was it again?
South?
West?
Southwest?
Southeast.
I just pulled my back.
Okay, we gotta lock in.
Oh my god, the segment is so long.
So long.
Like it that you play older, forgotten games.
Really?
You think so?
I don't feel like Mist is forgotten, per se.
Wait, is this just one?
That's just West, right?
That's wrong.
Oops, I did it again.
You played with the horse.
Got lost in the game.
I have to remember that drippy sound is west and sproingy
sound is east.
Old but not forgotten.
I think I missed this.
What?
That's northwest.
I see we are using technical terms, sproingy and drippy.
Are we almost there?
Is this it?
Is this the end?
Oh my god.
Northeast.
Zumbinis was such a goaded stream.
Oh my gosh, I missed Zumbinis so much.
Honestly, it's still one of my favorite streams that I've
done because I was just...
I was just so happy to play it.
I was just so happy to play Zumbinis!
Because I had been wanting to stream it for so long.
Because it really was like my favorite childhood game.
You're not fleens.
Well, whatever you are.
Make me a pizza.
Oh, Hamidou.
That's Southeast.
Make me a pizza.
So that's why I chose it as one of the first games that I
started.
once I got back.
Oh, I was so happy.
We made it.
Gosh, this was so stinking long.
The studio made a new game called Abduction some years ago
that's worth checking out if you want a more modern take.
Of Zumbinis?
Or of Mist?
Thanks for being here, but enjoy me.
Don't thank you, Sunday girl.
Thank you.
Zumbinis 2?
Nah, missed.
Well, why not more Zumbinis?
Why not?
Why can't we have more Zumbinis?
Oh my gosh, I'm so used to...
This is a hidey hole.
Right?
For someone's trying to kill me.
Maybe.
Serious?
Perhaps?
Try Princess, thank you!
I have returned.
Thank you for bringing me back.
You're welcome.
I see so much more like... legible.
You must continue to help me.
I must continue to help you.
My name is Ceres.
Hi Ceres.
I beg you to find me.
Remain Red Pages.
You must read.
He seems like such an...
To become what?
Release you from the book to become what?
I need more Red Pages.
I need more.
Why do they sound like this?
Don't waste time.
Don't...
That's what he just is like, I must go stream on my...
My brother.
Your brother?
What about him?
I like that guy.
He used to...
You didn't even...
Oh.
Oh, he is the one who is wrongfully imprisoned.
Bring the red page to me.
I just pulled Zaya.
Let's go, scuba!
Imagine if my lore video was like this.
I could just...
I imagine I could just see the viewership, like, dropping
and dropping and dropping.
We've gotten three pages, but I cannot remember.
We did the spaceship.
We did...
Oh, the gear?
And then we did this house.
Okay, now I remember.
I'm stupid.
to time this again.
No.
The tree.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't want to time.
Okay, let's go to the gear.
Fire that puppy up.
I've played golf in VR here.
I bet it's a really good golf map.
I bet.
Oh, uh, my bad.
Oh, la la la la la la la la la.
No, I should have gone the other way.
Okay, la la la.
Inside your riches.
I don't, I'm not interested in any of that.
Who am I?
Wait.
Sirius, your greed sickens me.
Your desire for wealth and plunder is never satisfied.
I will instruct my subjects not to pay your new tax.
And you know they'll listen to me.
Regards.
Eustace.
Your greed sickens me.
Sickening, sickening.
Greed.
Never-ending greed.
I'm glad I caught that.
I keep going the wrong way.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, did I just go the wrong way?
Just went the opposite way now.
Wait, what is the with the bird then?
and the snake
and the jemmies have so many questions does Eustace's room
got a note too I don't think so but it has a it has a
decomposing head so just props oh my gosh they really are
red herrings I've been fished I've been fished gotta love
how he treasures that note enough to keep it in his treasure
Bring me a green page.
Trust other wisps.
Wait.
Oh.
I think I just closed it.
Open.
In.
Go.
Green pages.
Only green.
All right.
Have returned.
What
are you saying?
My prison on this forgotten island of Mist.
I see that you are...
I'm wet.
I know your name.
I see that you are Minto.
You are green.
Red and green.
Christmas!
Don't touch the blue pages.
For my wicked brother.
Akano.
The wicked brother Akano.
He is a man of distorted mind and senses.
He disgusts me.
Why is he acting like this?
Do not release Akano.
Thirst for destruction is nigh.
Never ending.
Bring it to red paper.
Where are these guys now?
Can you please release me from this prison?
Okay.
Oh god.
Quite honestly, neither of them seem trustworthy.
Yeah, the actors.
Where are the actors at, I wonder?
Um, okay, let me save real quick.
I'll just save over Blue Pages team.
Oh, resume, there we go.
Um, what was the last thing?
The ship?
Is that what we need to do?
The sunken ship.
Which we, I have pictures, I believe, of, uh, yeah, of the
times that, the times and dates that I was given?
And I have the pictures of those the constellations.
And the red page in the forest.
Yeah, I know.
I just don't want to go get it.
I'm lazy.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
I'm lazy.
Ugh.
Oh, it's not even on.
Oh my gosh.
I have to relight it.
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh, there we go, okay.
Okay, we needed to go high up.
Actors are Robin and Rand Miller, two brothers, who are also
in the main developers of the game and in charge of...
Whoa, that's so cool!
Maybe that's enough.
Yes?
Okay.
Now it should be going up, up, up.
It's going up, up, up!
Maybe.
Oh!
Wait, is it already up?
I don't know.
Is it up at the top?
Oh!
Okay.
Maybe I should add more gas, gas, gas.
Hurry up, please.
Okay, there it is.
We'll let it get a little bit higher so that I'm not
scrambling to get inside.
Gas, gas, gas.
Gas, gas.
Alright, keep going, keep going!
Go in, no no, not yet, not yet, not yet.
I'm gonna let it get to like off the screen at least.
Off the screen at least, alright.
I gave it a lot of gas though.
You think it'll be okay?
I gave it so much gas.
Does it come down really?
Okay, let's go.
Squeakers, squeakin, squeak, squeak, squeak.
Squeakers and squeakin.
Oh, po po po po po.
Go, go, go!
Oh my gosh.
Go in!
Nice.
Okay, now we just gotta go grab that page.
We can come back.
I don't remember where this one was, though.
Like, I vaguely remember?
Can I get three big booms?
Boom!
Ah, yes, my swamp is.
ASMR.
My swamp.
Alright, it was somewhere amongst the trees.
I don't remember.
Do you guys remember?
Did I have to go up more?
Uh.
Oh shoot.
For some reason I was like, this will be so easy, I'll
remember.
I have to go higher.
Where's the next...
Oh, wait.
Was the elevator right next to me?
It was right next to me, wasn't it?
Oh, shoot.
How do I get back home?
Um...
Uh...
Oh, there, there, there, there, there, there.
Okay, at least it wasn't too far.
At least it was very close, actually.
Only one pump to change.
Yeah, it's not so bad.
All right, now we go to his fancy, fancy room.
Squillium fancy pants over here.
No, that's the ungabunga room.
That's not the right room either.
It's...
Oops.
It's the one over here.
And his was in here.
Here.
No.
Just kidding.
It was, uh...
And he... here!
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, I never forget.
I'm like an elephant.
I never forget.
Make a note of that note.
Oh, yeah.
I think I took a picture of it.
I'm almost positive I did.
Yeah, I took a picture of that note.
Alright.
Back down.
stars and then i think i need to redo that and then it was
like over here or something that i go around
yes yes
yes so would you play the sequel after this i'll think about
it it's definitely not off the table though I don't see why
not why did fart at me okay awesome guys we made it back now
we are three for three on both pages on both books
for each page I can see more clearly Free from this horrible
prison.
Oh.
You must visit the one remaining eight.
Because you have not the confidence that they're doing.
Yeah, I've heard a lot of people say that ribbon is, like,
so much more difficult.
And my brother Akana is invented.
I'm going to let that guy free.
I took advantage of the freedom of father and given us.
I never knew that this game had a story, though.
What did you say?
Speak up, Sirius.
Why so Sirius?
He will destroy both myself and me.
Just as he destroyed.
What's this about you murdering your friends?
either.
Imagine, like, you know when you're trying to, like, fix the
reception on a TV, like an old-timey TV, you had to move
the...
What's wrong with your face?
You have to move the antenna around.
Imagine you're just, like, trying to find the signal.
You have to move the page around.
Alright, quit yapping, Sirius.
Let me go down with it.
life and you will be riches beyond my wildest dreams
probably not this guy would give me like a nickel
maybe all right let's save again so i don't have to do all
of this stuff perfect okay now i have some constellations we
are trying to do something with this boat
I don't think there's anything else to do in here.
I think so.
Marker switch, water turbulent pool.
No, I don't think so.
Hmm.
There's also these.
And this.
What if I just grabbed it and pulled it up?
Hmm.
Is that a ladder?
Did you see one?
See green!
Green, green!
The library?
Oh, that's right!
There were... Oh, gosh, okay.
Okay, I'm just gonna skip through.
I'm sorry, guys.
I don't think... I don't think my throat has it in it to
read all of these pages.
I really apologize.
Because they're so long.
Oh, okay, just kidding.
In fact, as I say that, I'm going to put in a throat mint.
For myself.
Okay.
This is Papa.
Okay, this is the spaceship.
We have these nanograms, and there's many pages of them.
like 30 of them or something.
Cannibalism!
No.
This, I think, is it.
As for the boat, I can see the boys enjoying it anyway.
And with that, I am pleased.
They have played on it all day.
Even though the boat cannot move, I have enjoyed studying
from it.
It is much sturdier platform than the jagged rocks.
In the course of my observations, I have learned some very
interesting things regarding the solar system of this age.
Okay, here we go.
Nice or beautiful, constellations.
Mm-hmm.
Sorry.
Oh, 300!
300!
Keep going to the end.
Lighthouse.
There's not a lighthouse here.
It was Will who first saw the girl.
She was swimming not far from the boat where Will was...
Who was Will?
Then Will noticed a man not far away from the girl.
Emmett was very pleased to meet the additional neighbors.
Oh, I guess maybe in the Stone Ship Age.
Ten years since I left this age, which I've called the Stone
Ship Age.
Aw.
That has been kept in perfect condition.
Ah!
Here we go.
Okay.
Maybe the corresponding constellations are the things that I
light up green.
That is my guesstimation at the moment.
And we have three of them.
Which I have pictures of on my phone that I am currently
viewing.
But it is not this one.
Let's see.
It's not the eyeball.
Please be the snake.
Guys, it's the snake!
Okay, snake?
Yes.
Snake?
Snake is January 17th time.
Oh my god!
I manifested it.
Let's see.
Um, little buggy.
Little buggy!
Little buggy is November.
Little buggy.
Little buggy is November 23rd.
I don't know if I need to keep track of the dates or not,
but it's helping me with what I already knocked out.
Okay, not the cross, not the arrow, not the flamingo.
Leaf!
Leaf is October 11th.
Okay.
Very buggy.
Snake!
Okay, let's go outside.
How do I do?
Okay, there we go.
So, if I do snake green and which one's a little buggy, not
Not eyeball.
Little buggy, green.
Ooh, not flamingo.
Leaf.
Oh my god!
Thank you guys for reminding me about the book in the
library.
Wow!
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Oh, that's so cool.
Whoa.
I'm the captain of this ship.
Wow, there's nothing in here.
This area is...
Oh, there's the lighthouse.
Why is it under the water, though?
Do we have to lift it as well, like the boat?
What an odd rule.
room is that where he was he was like i like doing my
studies on the on the boat but it's like oh i guess he meant
these jagged rocks huh okay i am a i am a telescope that
only goes left and right
very cool
can i okay maybe i cannot what's in here Darkness.
Uh, up here?
This is where I came from, no?
Oh, it's now it's all covered in water.
This age is so fine, is it?
I'm excited.
Let's see still.
Oh.
What did I do?
And what's in here?
Oh!
Oh.
Okay.
Does it need to unlock that?
Interesting.
The key.
Alright, well it didn't lower the water in there.
What about... Oh wait, there is no water here.
What is this thing right here?
It looks like I should be able to interact with it, though.
The water here.
I don't know what it's doing.
How many games until the end of the year?
Oh, I would have to check.
I do not know off the top of my head, sorry.
Oh!
It did raise the water!
It did!
Wait, oh, shoot.
Okay.
I was like, I think it raises the water somewhere.
Alright, alright.
So what if we max it?
I hear it.
How are you?
It looks like there's something in here.
No, you guys would be very wrong about your answer.
If
I go back and there's stairs.
Oh, now it lets me down.
Okay, okay.
So maybe now this will float because I just let the water
out.
All right, now we raise the water again.
I'm pretty confident in my answer.
Nope, it's not here.
Oh,
there's...
Did I need to turn the handle?
Valve's still open.
Oh, but nothing's coming out.
Oh, maybe because it was...
Wait, which was closed and which was open?
Oh, wait.
This is closed.
Right?
It's closed now.
Okay, now it's good.
Oh, my gosh.
They're just like, hey, doofus, what do you think would
happen if you...
Oh!
Another key!
I'm upstairs.
What is this?
A bomb?
Wait, um...
I'm a little nervous.
I'm a little... It's green?
Oh, but it's going down.
Wait, is this really a bomb?
It looks like I'm charging something.
Yeah, like a battery.
Yeah.
Okay, full charge!
Oh, to what?
I'm like trying to see if I could touch anything but it
doesn't seem like it.
Alright, I'm gonna crank it some more.
We're cranking it.
All right, full charge.
I'm gonna leave.
Oh!
Oh, it's scary in here.
Wait, it's real.
Oh, I don't like it.
Oh, my God.
Get me out of here.
Okay.
Is there a way that I can get rid of this water?
I don't think the buttons worked.
I think I remember trying to press them.
And they didn't do anything.
I don't want to go back down in here, though.
I'm scared.
The buttons do work.
Oh, they do?
Maybe something in there will activate the one of the
buttons drains those tunnels.
Middle button.
Middle button it is.
Sorry if me zooming around is a little disorienting, guys.
Okay, here we go.
Maybe there's a button in here that will Turn on the lights
in the other room.
Whoa.
Oh, okay.
We know whose room this is.
Peels.
Peels here.
Okay.
Is that what he used to kill their dad?
Probably.
What a freak.
That guy is.
Look at this bed.
This absolute opulence.
Oh, my God.
god oh okay cool shut that oh okay oh my gosh okay red page
but i don't know how to go home yet oh my god oh this scared
me i thought i was running out of power how
much power do we have left oh we were so good.
Classy tableware.
For the classiest of men.
You escape so fast.
I was so scared!
Okay, we cranking it.
We'll go back now.
We'll go back to Sirus's room.
Why is his room in like the bunker bunker though?
What?
So if you care to find me, look to the western sky.
What the hell does that mean?
As someone told me lately.
What?
What purpose could this serve?
Imagine you go to the store.
I think I would be sold on it, too, though.
Think about it.
Mispredicted VTubers.
I want to go...
You think so?
I was watching the Defunct Land video the other day.
About, like...
The character, you know, there's, they have it now.
It's called, like, Turtle Talk, and then there's, like, one
where you can talk to Stitch, too.
But, like, truly, they have, Disney invented VTubers.
Disney's the one that started it, I fear.
I just want to keep clicking on this guy.
If you don't know what, if you haven't watched the video,
basically, like I don't want the power to go out basically
there was like a little room where you could go and talk to
Stitch and like some guy was controlling like the facial
motions and it wasn't like a like a you know a camera or
anything he had like a joystick and was like like a
controller and was like using the joystick to look up and
over and, like, also using the buttons to control, like, the
facial expressions, um, which is, I mean, my face is my own,
so I control my own face, but, um, totally have not seen
that being done with, uh, you know, VTubers before, ever.
No, it's everybody, it's their own face.
Yeah, puppeteering, exactly.
And so, um, uh, and so, did I get this right?
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, it was basically just like a meet and greet with a
V-Tuber.
It was so funny.
Okay, let's go crank it again.
I'm cranking it in the lighthouse!
Okay, we're not even like...
Dang, this thing is generous.
Minto is a Muppet.
No!
If I were a Muppet, put me on a game of wars.
It's so funny how many people get angry about Miss Piggy
being there.
Does that mean we're all technically Disney adults?
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
Is there something in this room that I'm like supposed to...
Maybe there's something that I'm supposed to press.
Oh my god, it sounds so icky.
Please let there be a light switch.
Somewhere, light switch.
Light switch?
Light switch.
I'm missing something.
Okay, definitely figured that was the case.
Did I know what to do with this yet?
Oh, nothing, apparently.
Uh, how did I...
Oh, yeah, I click and drag.
That's right.
Can I go the other way?
10 20 30 40 50 60 80 90 100 110 what was that 120 130 what
if they put a jump scare in here that'd be horrible oh fine
there's also like over here
That...
What is... wait.
Oh, I have been there.
Oh, those are the buttons.
Okay, just kidding.
That's these.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, the pump station.
What?
What could there be?
Time for me to be a gamer and look up.
Hmm.
Take it slow on the stairs down to Saris's room.
I did actually...
Whoops.
I did think about that.
So, I was like, maybe I'm going too fast.
Maybe there's something here.
Okay.
Okay, that just turned me around.
Wait a second.
There's nothing there.
Wait.
That just turned me around.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, I did.
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Uh, uh.
Huh?
I'm not trying to leave.
I'm trying to, like, go down here.
Oh!
I lit it up.
Oh.
Something is illuminating in the water.
Wait, what did I do?
Did
she get that first try?
Was there something special about it?
Oh, oh, don't touch anything else.
Guys, what have I told you that I'm a genius or why?
What have I told you?
Oh wait, actually that should light up his room.
Okay, let's go crank it.
That should...
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go crank it.
That part gave me nightmares as a kid because pressing the
wrong one makes a loud sound.
No way!
Wait, out of all of those?
How did I get the right one first try?
How?
I think I am a secret genius.
I'm a secret genius!
Oh, here we go.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Ew.
Whoa.
We found the book to go home.
Okay, bye.
Well, where's our blue?
page i won't rest and well i guess we can go home for now
and then we'll come back because we have to find where
you're gotcha look with yo madeani welcome to membership
thank you
there are two tunnels one for each brother wait gave her
genius i've never seen anyone just raw gesso puzzle i didn't
even know it It was a puzzle.
I didn't even know.
It was a puzzle.
I just did it.
Okay.
Come on.
Telescope was the hint to the solution.
That's what I figured!
Oh.
You finally discovered.
I owe you a debt of gratitude for you have nearly My name is
Sirius.
Yeah, I know.
I trust that from your explorations, you become convinced
that my wicked brother, Akanah, is guilty, and I am
innocent.
No.
It is I who am wrongly imprisoned here.
Prisoned by my father.
You pranked that soldier boy first, Trump.
I don't know who you are or how you came to this country.
I don't know either.
You must at least know something at the point.
whose father was a master of the books he wrote hundreds of
all describing and linking to the fantastic places and ages
which he had discovered the room in which you now stand was
our father's library yeah it was here in this room on this
island named Mist that he housed most of his books but such
a waste now discovered that Akanah has burnt you to the
innermost.
Our father was always watchful of our explorations.
We grew up under his strict supervision.
But when we came of age, he gave us unbridled access to the
mystic books.
He began to leave our adventures more and more unchecked.
Unsupervised as we were, my brother began to become
disturbed.
He began to take more from the mist ages than he had given
him soon reigned a twisted pleasure from the conquest and
destruction why does nose go like that okay Pinocchio
telling lies huh uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
he had completely destroyed all of the mist ages I wasted no
time.
In warning, my father, I thought he would work away from the
camera.
But in a fit of rage, he imprisoned both my brother and
myself within the pages of these books designed to hold us
until he could judge which of us was killed.
Yeah, but I thought the father was dead.
Discover the truth.
Our father embarked on one final adventure.
Oh.
However, he has never returned.
I can only assume that he perished along the way, leaving
me, an innocent victim and trapped forever.
But now, you are here to release me.
Listen carefully.
Okay.
You must find one more page, and I will be forever free.
There is a book on the shelves.
This library, which is mostly burned, but has a few pages
still intact.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
It is the last...
book on the middle shelf oh the one with all the no no
grounds filled with a variety of patterns yeah find pattern
158 and recreate it on the door of the fireplace and this
will bring you to the last red page okay bring that page to
me and i will finally be released and able to reward you 158
we got it yeah i wrote it down even ignore the blue page
ignore the blue page that page my brother's children to even
think what will happen if you were to release him there is
another one oh yeah where the red and blue pages reside also
resides a green book there is a green book you also will be
imprisoned forever what I get to be in the green this same
morning I suggest you follow us God,
all right, let's go get, let's go get brothers page as well.
Let's head back to the ship world.
I didn't see where it was, though.
We're going to have to find it.
And then I'll start doing, then I'll start doing separate
saves for the other endings.
Are the other, are the other endings like long or anything
or?
Actually, it's pink.
dokey dokey let's go crank it in the lighthouse
green book not really okay cool
oh not enough you're very close to the end this is wow this
game took me years to figure out with a little help from
chat you've nailed it in two streams i know somehow thank
you guys for all your help you've really been You've been,
uh, I feel you guys have been really good about, um, not
giving me direct answers, just, uh, you, sometimes,
sometimes you do, but, about helping me with, like, little
directions.
I always thought this game would be impossible for me to
complete, you know, like, when you're a baby, it's just
like, sometimes these games are, like, They feel...
I feel like it's gotta be in there, no?
There's another...
No!
The lie is off!
Oh, how annoying.
There is another passage.
You're just going to the same...
Going down the same...
I tried!
I really did try!
It wouldn't let me!
Am I crazy?
Alright, let's try again.
So...
Wait, where is it?
Here.
Oh my gosh, how are you supposed to see that?
Like this?
Which one was it?
Oh, it does make a big noise.
Oh, it's scary.
Wait, what am I supposed to do?
Oh, scary.
Oh, that's scary.
Oh, I'm glad I saw what happens, though.
That's freaky.
Oh, my gosh.
That would give me nightmares, too.
Graphics in this game were amazing in 1993.
Yeah, I could believe it.
That would give me...
That would give me nightmares.
Holy cow.
I just exited the second tunnel.
have to, like, direct me hard because I'm getting lost,
lost, lost.
Jarvis, rewind the VOD.
Blue attack?
Oh, wow.
Thank you for this fucking dono!
I vote we release both brothers and let them fistfight on
top of one of those giant battle gears.
I agree with this plan.
Entrance to the other room is on the other side of the
island.
Wait, am I getting one god?
From outside, there's a Searist tunnel.
Wait, oh.
From outside.
This one?
No way.
It was...
It was that obvious.
Holy...
Wait, why is he got poison here?
What is this?
Okay.
Interesting decor.
Oh, his bed is horrible.
It's like Virgil and Dante.
It really is.
Yes, it really is.
What the heck is this?
The beautiful rose is actually death.
He just has that.
He just owns that.
The other half!
Wait, the vault?
Wait, wait, wait.
The vault is...
is located in very plain view on the islands of Mist.
An access can be achieved very easily if the simple
instructions are followed.
First locate each of the marker switchers on the island.
We did that.
Turn every one of these switches to the on position.
Then go to the dock and as a final step, turn the marker
there to the off position.
So we turn every single single... Wait, I feel like I did
that.
So we turn all the switches on the island on, and then we
turn the one on the dock off.
All on except dock.
Another map.
Okay, buddy.
Whoa, these are sick.
Whoa, freaky.
All right, let's grab this page.
Thank you.
There I go.
I might be able to make it without the water or without the
light, I feel.
Maybe.
Let's try.
Oh,
it won't let me.
Oh, that's evil.
Okay.
That's mean.
Yeah, you need the light.
Dang it.
I feel like I did that thing with the dock.
Oh, whoops.
Because.
I feel like I...
I was just messing with the switches.
Which one was it, guys?
Is it this one?
I remember just clicking a random one.
135 degrees.
Bottom right red.
This one?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
I appreciate you all so much.
Otherwise, we just would have been...
Oops.
We just would have been...
I would have...
Obviously, I...
You know, I could do the puzzle.
Obviously, I could do the puzzle, but at the same time,
we're just trying to...
I thought I already did it, so.
Even if it was by action.
Ah!
Alright, we're just trying to get in and out so we can get
the pages.
Oh my gosh, why one...
Okay, let's listen to his mad rambling.
things.
Hello.
Hi, Agna.
You, sis.
I'm glad to see that you've returned to help me escape from
my wrongful imprisonment.
He was seriously did this for me.
I was your brother.
Do not listen to him.
I warn you.
He's a liar.
He can't be persuaded by his evil lies.
My reason?
To kill my father.
He will kill you.
What did he do to your father?
It began when my brother Sears began to muster the riches.
He stole from the ages of mist.
The only riches wore himself.
Evil lies.
Father swept away his watchfulness.
My sick brother secretly pronounced himself king.
King of the ages of mist, he said.
He began to look upon me in disgust.
brother he's him his lovely brother and that's serious began
to destroy the ages of mr.
burn their forest he tore down the structures and flooded
their lands murdered their inhabitants he destroyed all but
four of the ages of course I had a woman father I finally
found him there was serious oh talking cleverly
I don't know why I believe this guy over Sirius.
It was I who was greedy for wealth and plunder.
He seriously dealt with the final blow.
He kicked the father into believing that I was the murderer.
Like, he just seems so believable compared to Sirius.
Yeah, he gives more details for sure.
He has doubted my brother's clever lies.
it's so enjoying father imprisoned us both i'm sure from
which of us the flow had come thank you what i say is true
release me you must release me my brother is a secret liar
and deserves punishment i only wish vengeance for my dear
father he's murdered believe me you must only recover one
additional page to release me from this prison okay yeah
yeah isn't fine listen bookshelf library 150 a right middle
shelf there's a burned book which is different 150 a 150 a
is filled with 50 patterns fine pattern 158 yeah mimic its
design on the panel in the fireplace doing this really on
the last blue page okay remember take the red page only the
blue page what about the green book green book yeah yeah oh
yeah oh it's so tempting I've been hoping for a green book
all
righty everybody oh my god Oh, there's a door.
There's a door on the fireplace?
Okay, 158.
158.
Okay.
All right, let me take a quick little photograph.
Look at this graph.
Okay.
All right, now I save.
Save.
I'm gonna do...
Okay, we're gonna...
This is how I'll remember.
Blue...
That was blue pages.
Then we have red page.
And then we have...
Wait, oh, I did not save.
Ah, ah, ah, save.
Wait, save.
Red page.
Save.
Then we save.
This is how I'll remember.
Then we have green book.
Save.
And then we have...
Mysterious lever?
Oh, I guess I should have saved after the fireplace, huh?
Whatever.
I can resave.
It's fine.
What did he say?
The door on the fireplace.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I didn't notice that before!
Volume check?
Okay, thank you.
How do I do this?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, so far so good.
Okay, you can undo one if you mess up.
Three, four, five.
Okay, so far so good.
That should be it.
Ha!
Okay, awesome.
It's right there.
Okay, now.
Now I'm going to save again.
Sorry, I'm going to save everything.
Just so I can...
I don't know if...
Save.
I'm probably overthinking this completely, but whatever.
I just want to make sure I get everything, you know.
And save.
Okay.
Let's...
Dude...
Wait.
You know what?
I don't remember what I did.
Let's do the green...
No!
I'm good?
Okay, cool.
What did I save last?
You know what?
I'm gonna... This is so stupid.
I'm going to load... We're gonna load the blue pages.
No!
I'm gonna... Because I'm... Okay, I want to do the one that
I'm the least confident in.
So we're gonna load the red pages.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
It puts me here.
Interesting.
So if I go into the fireplace...
Oh.
It.
Does it make me do it again?
Oh, that's...
That's stinky.
Oh, that's stinky.
Okay.
Sorry, guys.
I didn't know.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
That was a volume one.
Memorize it?
Yeah, I'll memorize it.
Don't worry.
Okay, that should be it.
Nice.
I think I chose the red page first, so let's do red page.
Let's go
Oh my god, no, he just fades Yes Oh, yes Oh, yes Oh, yes
Thank you, my friend Why is he so so My dear friend, you've
done the right thing.
You stupid fool.
It looks like perhaps you're in the book now.
Oh my god, this accent is killing me.
A page.
No, no.
No!
I hope you enjoy your music.
home as much as i am wait is this gonna happen with
no our connection you're getting nice clear i hope you're in
the booths mcdonald's wi-fi oh my god the library looks much
the same as hello oh i can know Oh my
god, please.
Just put me out of my misery.
I can't understand you anymore.
Oh, I understood that, though.
Was that it?
That was it.
No stinking way, this guy.
First bad end.
Oh my gosh.
Bro's streaming from his microwave.
Ah!
I have to load!
Okay, I think?
Okay, I think I have to...
Okay, load.
Alright, so that was the red page.
Let's do the blue page.
We're still the same thing's gonna think it happened!
We're gonna give...
I expected him to say, do you like my sunglasses?
I know!
We're gonna give sucked into the book oh my god okay let me
pull this up again sorry so loud i make it quiet even for me
okay almost there
Blue page.
Maybe Akanar will be a nice guy.
Maybe he'll, like, we'll switch places and then he'll be
like, Alright, buddy, I'm gonna get you out of there.
Like, right now.
I know how.
He'll help me for sure.
I wonder what picture this No No Crab makes.
A cat.
Oh my gosh, we're in the book.
It's so funny that it's so tiny.
Oh yes, afraid!
Oh, I feel alive!
How do you feel, my friend?
Oh, whatever here.
Perhaps Pages, you act so hard for.
Yeah, yeah.
What?
Yeah, why are they laughing?
so much.
I'm out of the book!
Y'all seen the world from my point of view!
Yes!
Oh.
No!
Why are you so evil?
Did he just go Twitter?
Maybe someone will rescue you someday.
They both suck!
Put me out of my misery.
I lose!
Serious is greedy, Akinar is a sadist, they both suck.
Oh my god, he's still ripping out pages!
He's still going!
Bad end number two.
do you guys think i should do the green book or i should
actually i kind of want to do the green book so i can get it
out of the way but this guy seems so trustworthy and stable
how could this have happened i loved actar and his giddy
giggles yay okay load now we'll do the green book load load
Where's my phone?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
One more time in the fireplace.
Getting all dirty in there.
Okay, I turn it down so you guys don't have to hear.
Well, I hope it's one more time in the fireplace, you know.
We gotta go rescue Papa.
We gotta go rescue Daddy.
What's his name?
I don't know.
Why are both of your children assholes?
Two more times.
Atrus.
One more time for the fourth ending.
Oh, dang.
Okay.
Well, that's fine.
Let's just get it out of the way.
Who the devil are you?
Don't come here to Dunny.
Not yet.
Oh, I have many questions for you, my friend.
As you no doubt have for me.
Um, where should I begin?
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Yeah?
Why is your connection so good?
My name is Atris.
I feel you've met my son, Sirius and Akanah.
I have, unfortunately.
Yeah.
Missed Island.
In my library.
My library.
Oh.
It contains my works, my writings.
Why are you in there?
Oh, I wrote many books.
It linked me to fantastic places.
It's an art I learned from my father many years ago.
Oh, but the red and blue books, those were different.
I wrote those books too, in trap over greedy explorers that
might stumble upon my island of mist.
But I had no idea my own sons would be entrapped.
my sons yeah they're poopy I gave them free reign to looks
yeah perhaps it was not wise yeah I think that was a mistake
I think they needed a father figure instead of running
around and different I had not told them about the red and
blue books gave them my parents exactly while they dreamed
of riches and power of course they did not know the books
were traps oh they begged for access to those books and I of
course denied them ah typical typical modern-day parents
they devised a plan an evil plan sorry I'm trying to what
extent some throat spread I think I'm out though and I
forgot to buy more in Japan their own mother feels their own
mother oh my dear Catherine her to lure me here to Dunny of
course I I could return to mist except that yeah they
removed a single page from my mist linking oh no I cannot
return without that page you my friend can bring that page
to me but then I'll be stuck in your Oh, I pray you believe
my story above the lies that my sons have told you.
If you could find it in yourself to return that page to me
here in Dunney, I could go to Mist and bring justice to my
sons for what they have done.
I must return to my writing.
I pray that you believe me.
Please, sorry.
Where's your page?
Bring the page with you.
Oh, his book is a child.
if you go in without the okay that's what he said don't go
to me right if i click on him is that a is that another
ending so wait if i click on it and go in there that's an
ending and then if i go and do the bow is that a different
ending that is the bad ending three and then the fourth
ending is going to get the page is that what it is you get
the funniest crash out let's go okay okay cool oh what where
are we hi whoa he
hasn't noticed me yet
ah my friend you've returned we need face to face in the
page did you bring the page no You didn't bring Paige.
No, sorry.
You didn't bring Paige.
I'm sorry.
I don't...
Who are you?
Oh.
Did you not take my warning seriously?
My finger slipped.
He's so mad.
Welcome to dummy.
To dummy?
Welcome to dummy?
Not the clowns.
Is that it?
What about this thing?
I'm looking at it.
That's it?
I just disappointed him.
Is there anything to eat in here?
Dunny.
Oh, dunny.
Welcome, dummy.
Alright, reload again.
Reload, reload!
Alright, let's do our mysterious lover.
can i find the page before i go in there
actress has a food age somewhere but it's not in the game oh
dang yes okay let's do that then all right now uh before i
do this
one two three
six seven so all i have should have to do is i think they're
all still pulled whoops ostrich flamingo whichever ending
three two dummies and dunny stop it stop it okay oh i think
what oh oh i found it This is why I stick to manga and
comics.
Always judge books by their cover.
Oh.
Um.
Okay.
No stinking way.
That was so...
Wait, seriously?
Okay.
All right, one last time.
Country roads.
Take me home to the place I belong West Virginia Mountain
mama Take me home Country roads
Here I go.
Ah,
my friend.
You retire.
Give the page.
Give it to me.
Wait, hold on.
Give me the page.
Okay, hold on.
Please give the page.
One second.
Someone said it's their birthday.
This is my birthday.
Can you please sing me a silly little birthday song?
Lauren Sachi!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Lord Stargy.
Oh,
one more time.
It's your birthday today.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy,
happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy,
happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy,
Attress!
God!
I have a difficult choice to make.
Reach over the page!
Yes?
Why?
Why are you- My sons have betrayed me.
I know what I must do.
Yeah.
I shall return shortly.
Oh, you're not gonna leave me here though, right?
Wait, what about me?
Give me the page.
Please give it to me.
The page, my friend, the page.
Uh...
Are you killing him?
Can I sit there?
Hello?
Wait, what just happened?
Wait, I...
I skipped it!
Oh,
kidding!
Um, wait, I don't- Okay, let me just load it again.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I have to do it all over again.
Reload.
Okay, wait.
I have to go find the page.
I have to go get it first.
Okay, on our way back.
Oh my god.
I did all that stalling for one.
One more time!
This is karma for waking you, boy.
I think so, I think so.
Ximong, thank you so much for the fun!
Good to thank you!
Happy birthday to you with you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
To everyone.
Happy birthday to you.
Okay, I'm gonna save while I'm in there.
And maybe that will do the trick.
Maybe that will do the trick.
Happy birthday, everybody.
Just sit when he disappears.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna save.
Birthday song.
Let's see.
All right.
I'm here.
Ah, my friend.
Yep.
You returned.
Give me the page.
You won it?
Please give the page.
Yeah, you win the page.
Yeah.
You win the page.
You win the page, my friend.
Yeah.
You want the page?
Oh, do you want the page?
No, do you want the page?
Okay.
You've done the right thing.
The page, my friend.
The page.
I have a difficult choice to make.
All right, I'm just gonna sit here.
I'm not gonna move at all, okay?
We're just gonna sit.
And we're gonna wait.
What's the prog- what's the diagnosis, Doc?
They betrayed you!
I shall return shortly.
Okay!
I won't go anywhere!
I won't go anywhere.
My hands are off the keyboard, they're in my pants.
Oh, he's back!
It is done.
Did you kill him?
Great time, thank you!
I have many questions for you, my friend.
writing cannot wait.
I fear that my long delay may have already had a
catastrophic impact on the world in which my wife Catherine
is now being held hostage.
What?
Where?
Where is Catherine?
And the reward, I'm sorry, but all I have to offer you is
the library on the island of in the books that are contained
there feel free to explore at your leisure i hope you find
your explorations satisfying thank you you will no longer
have my sons to deal with oh okay awesome wait how did i get
here oh and uh one more favor yes colombo i am fighting a
foe much greater of my sons who'd even imagine at some point
in the future.
I may find it necessary to request your assistance.
Me!
Until that point, feel free to enjoy the explorations from
my library on Mist.
Thank you again.
Thank you!
That's not it?
That's the ending?
Congratulations on beating Mist!
When back the man on the floor and...
The book.
You can use the Mist to make your book to And I is the man
who modeled the room.
Oh, cool.
Or dummy.
Dunny.
How do I...
Oh, here we go.
We did it!
What?
That was an ending...
Wait.
Oh my god!
He really did kill them.
Oh my god.
They're dead!
Wow.
He killed them.
Well, guys.
That's another...
And we got all the endings!
Woohoo!
Yeah!
He unalived them.
Let me add that to my...
My drive, my list, my Excel sheet.
Um...
Let's see.
12, 12, 16, 20, 25.
Miss!
Yeah!
Whoa, whoa!
Yippee!
We did it.
How many left now?
Six.
Six games left!
I feel like they missed an opportunity in this one.
We're traversing books, yes, but we're not.
Where's the de-boning one of them?
I don't want to go there.
Six left.
And then tomorrow, I should be able to beat Untitled Goose
Game.
So then it will be five.
And I have a couple games lined up.
I have three games lined up to beat.
So I just have to come up with two more games.
And I should be able to complete 50 games this year.
I remember playing this with my mom way back then Thanks for
the memories and don't play mystery unless you have an
engineering degree Oh, whoa I don't know, maybe we could do
Riven But it seems to be a longer Game, no?
I'm not opposed to playing it In general, but
It's much longer Yeah, yeah, I've heard, I've heard, I've
heard Just curious, have you ever tried melting Andy's
chocolate mints in coffee or hot chocolate?
Oh, I have before!
Yes, it's so good!
That's so good!
Play it next year sometime.
Yeah, I think that's the plan.
What about starting a new series for your last one?
I will not have a...
Yakuza Zero!
I will not have enough time to complete a long game like
that, unfortunately.
Yakuza!
Damn!
Right now I'm kind of doing only like one shot.
Uh...
Yeah.
You go through the bookshelf and the library?
Yeah, I had to.
That's how you get the hints for the game.
Thank you for the summertime!
Xibong, thank you!
For the last two games you should do some humongous
entertainment games.
Oh, like...
Like PUTPUT?
Or Freddy Fish?
Oh my gosh, wait, could we do?
I loved Freddy Fish in the haunted schoolhouse.
That was the only one I ever played because it was a haunted
schoolhouse.
And I wanted to play.
Another one.
Can we see the full list at the end of the year?
Yeah, of course!
I will, of course, post it.
Once again, I highly recommend playing Riven and Miss 3.
You're super good in Riven.
Yeah, yeah.
Riven is on the list.
Don't worry.
Are you planning to finish Battle Block with Barry?
That's on the list!
Yep, yep.
Oh, and it's pretty short.
It's by the Limbo game that's designed it.
Yeah, but Limbo ended up taking me two streams and I thought
it would only take me one.
Freddy Fish, though.
Freddy Fish would be fun.
Shout out one of my favorite childhood games.
The Day the World Broke.
I always thought it had a similar vibe to Miss and with a
touch more whimsy and talking mechanical ammish.
Cool.
Never heard of it.
Sierra games like Space.
quest police quest etc maybe yeah yeah i think we could do
freddy fish no half-life episodes i determined that i
probably wouldn't be able to finish them in time or rather
in one stream so i'm trying to really only focus on games
that i can do in one stream um yeah yeah i thought for some
reason i thought mist would be able to be one stream but Or
originally, I think I was planning on doing it in one
stream, and then I had the meeting, and then the meeting did
not happen, so...
Yeah, mischanged the trajectory of my tasting gaze.
Whoa!
It's a bit rough as it was an indie game for a long time
ago.
The sequels are great.
Yeah!
Journeyman project a look.
Very similar gameplay with time travel.
I like it.
But I'll come up with some stuff, so...
could have without the meeting yeah i actually planned on
finishing it in one go but then the meeting happened i was
like okay well i'll get through 50 of the game which
happened and then yeah but it's all good it's all good i'm
gonna put freddy fish on my list ready wait can i even get
that on steam let's see i might have to find it elsewhere
Freddy...
Five nights at Freddy's.
Freddy fish.
They do have it.
Wait, did they have the haunted?
They have the haunted schoolhouse!
That's my favorite one.
It's the only one I've ever...
I say it's my favorite, it's the only one I've ever played.
I didn't really care about games unless they had spooky,
like...
I don't think...
Like, similar to, like, I-Spy.
Haunted Mansion, that was the only I-Spy I ever played
because it was a haunted mansion.
And Freddy Fish, I only played it because it was Haunted
Schoolhouse.
I only liked spooky games when I was...
Yeah.
At least you're on brand.
Always happened, always happened.
leave you guys here though because my throat is starting to
hurt so thank you everybody thank you for missed oh my gosh
we beat it we beat it we big-brained and everything so thank
you so much thank you thank you and i will see you guys when
i see you next hopefully tomorrow for untitled goose game
and if not then i'll see you whenever oh sorry that's freddy
fish Doryko, thank you so much for the pink!
Thank you!
Hope you have a fun actual meeting.
Yes.
Oh, wait.
When is that?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In 30 minutes.
Cool.
Okay, okay.
What's up, you guys, everyone?
Thank you so much.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Thank you!
Bye-bye.